and we're looking outside right now
Sherry Smith because as we're getting
ready to go and trying to loosen up it
takes a little extra to warm up it sure
does if you're going to go out for a run
or a bike ride or something this morning
of course put on some warmer layers but
do some stretching first because it is
definitely cold out there oh boy we
still have just beautiful views of the
snow look at that we're looking out
towards the mountains this morning we're
expecting to get more snow as we get
through tonight checking Valley
temperatures I just updated them we're
in the 30s even below freezing Seven
Hills freezing at Mountain's Edge it's
20s up in Indian Springs Pahrump you're
at freezing Boulder City is very close
at 34 and so is Mesquite red rocket 26.
now Kyle Canyons at 31 because you're
getting some more wind up there in the
mountains so kiddos I'm not joking about
putting on some warmer coats this
morning 35 is an average Step this
afternoon 52 with just a slight chance
of showers by the time that school bell
rings and you're getting home A really
later chance in to the late afternoon
and early evening hours is a better
chance for some showers could be mixing
with some snow this is going to be a
fast moving system we don't expect
anything to really stick but we might
get a dusting here there with really low
snow levels that could reach the valley
a Gusty chilly North Wind set up tonight
into Friday and then we're just we've
got cool days and cold mornings really
all the way into next week so this
system is moving in right now into the
Great Basin spreading snow into Northern
Nevada a little bit of rain in
California not nearly what they've seen
in the last systems this one's coming
out of Canada so it's cold look at all
the winter weather advisories including
our own local mountains right here in
the spring mountains 10 a.m this morning
to 10 a.m 4 P.M is for Utah but on
Friday 10 a.m on Friday for us and then
wind advisories areas west of Las Vegas
not including us we'll have 25 30 plus
mile an hour winds tomorrow out of the
North and they're going to be cold but
those areas are going to have 40 plus 52
for a high today day and we'll keep it
pretty much in the mid to low 50s
through the weekend tomorrow is going to
feel extra cool though with those winds
so that chance of showers up until maybe
midnight and that's about it 6